well you could definitely see that he's
a beautiful spirit do you think that
because he struggled for many years that
that actually gives him much more
compassion people yes I believe so I
believe so and also I think I'm and he
didn't mention this at some point that
it was his age like if it thinks had
happened to him like this whole journey
gig happened in his early to mid-20s he
said he'd have gone crazy he would have
gone really like off the hook but the
fact that he had lived that rock and
roll life without the money and he was
now in his 40s had learned his lesson he
was so thankful that it happened to him
then because then he could really
observe it take it all in knew that it
would never be forever he knows that
it's like things and right he's very
practical and so it keeps him grounded
you know there's a certain wisdom in our
now that um very rare cuz you know some
40 year olds never get there right or
drifty or 60 yeah yeah um and yeah he's
just a very grounded person smart
you